do the two of you create stories for the
market i know that's a big
dilemma when you make a movie you know
you kind of have to consider a lot of
things
um because you don't just make it for
yourself you have to consider the fans
what they like you do think of what's
trendy
but you know you also know till you're
gonna finish
post-production whatever is trending now
it's not gonna be trendy in a year
so you kind of have to almost take a
chance what we do lately is just kind of
take a chance and do some things that we
think they're original
they haven't been made before it's not
just trendy
because if it's trendy you just have to
do it fast and that's a machine that's a
factory and we just don't do that
other companies do that that's great we
don't do that
so then we're just kind of going more on
our guts on what we know about the genre
we get inspired from various movies from
different time periods
what we know fans like and uh what we
like to do
to contribute and like i said you just
sometimes just take a chance and see
what people
they like it or not but you have to put
something out there that
you like and you hope other people will
like but
we do always think of fans of other
people
and you know you do think um you want
your movie to be easily
marketed to have something new and fresh
and brings a new original concept you
don't you want it to stand out
in the crowd because a lot of people are
making movies it's a lot of competition
out there
so you don't want your movie to be one
of the whatever new slasher movies or
you know okay it's
zombie movies are popular okay let's
make one of those we don't want that
we're trying to
create whatever your budget is sometimes
you have more money sometimes you don't
but you're trying we're trying to do
something more original and contribute
and make it stand out
you do kind of especially brad is very
good about like the tile make sure it
hasn't done before it's cool it's new
it's fresh
concept sometimes we come up with the
artwork before the script is even
finished
just to create something that you know
we haven't done we haven't seen before
and just makes your movies stand out
because speaking of distribution
and festivals they want
things that stand out it's easy easier
for them to
market things if you know what you're
doing and you bring them something more
interesting and different
so a theme i'm picking up is that you
you like to do things that are
new and that you haven't done before you
don't want to be
regurgitating sort of the same thing
again no because we started by doing
that
and you do a lot of programmers or
things
like that and look there are fun and you
have to make a living
and you try even those to contribute
things
but you know lately we're kind of like
look you know we're not getting any
younger and you just want to contribute
more than you know just make a movie
that is like 100 other movies we're just
trying to do
things are more interesting for us to
explore
um that we haven't done before because
you know okay slasher it's good
fun but and you know bread is known for
some slashers and everything and i'm not
saying i'm not gonna do that ever again
but if i would do it
once again i would try to you know break
the tradition
come up with something different just
you know just keep people guessing and
also make it more fun and interesting
than the same
thing over and over again i mean you
know it's boring i think for everybody
so once you finish a project how much
time
do you give yourself in between or you
don't do you give yourself like a
resting period
to kind of rejuvenate or no because it
must take a lot out of you
it does it does take a lot of us because
we're like you know guiding a project
for years
um ideally that would be nice to
have a break but that doesn't always
happen most of the time it has doesn't
happen like
right now we have high def coming out
and we're already working on the next
movie
so prepping different things you know um
so you know it just kind of happens uh
because you know
in the same time some projects are gonna
drag longer in post or something so at
least till you get to the point that you
get them in the can you're trying to get
things going
um as much as possible not let the
momentum going either
you know because things tend to take
longer than you'd like to sometimes so
it's better to get
on on it but ideally yeah that would be
nice to have a bit of a break but
like i said that doesn't always happen
it's not even if
you're in charge you're not it's not
always you know
up to you and every movie it's it's
different has its own journey
you know sometimes you know we used to
make movies for distributors when we
were doing that they had a release date
set already so before we
even shooting when you won't be coming
out so you really can't
drag your feet to that nowadays we don't
do that but
in the same time we do kind of set
ourselves some sort of deadline because
otherwise things are never going to get
finished um so with high def we had like
a festival deadline
it wasn't like no we didn't have to be
like completely
finish finished in post but at least get
to a certain phase to be
acceptable to present to a festival
because otherwise
people can keep dragging things and you
know
slow down the process so i think we all
need deadlines but yeah in an ideal work
world i would like to have
a few breaks in between definitely
at what point do you think a filmmaker
is ready to take on investors
you know you're never ready you just
have to just
start to do it you know just just have
have the chance
um to take the chance or try you know
you can't just wait for somebody to let
you do something
or you know sure you do have to be
prepared you can just
come out of film school and not have any
experience and
think you're gonna you know get a lot of
money to make a big movie or something
but i think it's good to work on sets i
think it's good to gather experience
because when you get in a meeting with
investors
they'll know that you know what you're
talking about and that i think it's
important
but um
i don't think you're ever ready i think
at some point you should just
take a risk and just go for it and see
what happens
because i don't think it's good to wait
forever
for um things to happen you're never
ready
uh people can you know think of oh i
still need more money to make my movie
and still have some money that you know
i
got already in the bank but i'm still i
still need more um
they always want everything to be
perfect and
as much as you try it's not gonna be
perfect but it's better just to go and
do it
and you learn from that and you'll have
a movie then just wait for years to get
a bit more money and you'll never make
a movie so i think it's better just to
like sometimes just take the chance and
go for it
i mean when i first started to produce i
mean was i ready
i don't know i mean pardon me up i i was
and i was
i thought i was but i wasn't like
overthinking it you know i already
had some experiences learned some things
and you just kind of have to go and do
it but you know
when you know our first day of shoot um
you know we scouted the location big
time it was a river going through it all
of a sudden it was a lot of rain from
our last
scout and it was a river going through
uh the area that we had to like and
almost build a bridge to carry equipment
to go to the woods we needed to shoot
well was i prepared for that no i wasn't
but you just sometimes just to kind of
roll up your sleeve and
that's what's called filmmaking you just
kind of have to be very flexible
and you know learn how to deal with
every situation no i was not prepared
for that it's not what i thought i'm
going to be doing that day
but so what you know movie got finished
so that's what it matters and it makes
for a
funny story now even if it was really
stressful back then
you